hello my fellow nerds and happy tuesday
carlos here i got a quick little
update about thor love and thunder
coming from down
under no spoilers here so watch it to
your heart's content
this is et canada's nerd alert
remember about a month ago when we said
that idris elba could be returning to
thor love and thunder as heimdall
well over the weekend the star was
spotted at an 80s themed party with matt
damon
and chris hemsworth following the events
of avengers end game
i'll have to wait and see how marvel
could bring him back because
well he's dead but i mean we have been
watching a whole series where one of the
main characters
isn't exactly alive so where do things
have happened in the mcu
now we haven't seen any shots of idris
on set with the crew but new photos do
show
matt on set and a familiar look from
thor ragnarok with sam neil as odin
and chris's brother luke fully decked
out as the mighty thor
i'm sorry about that thing with the
tesseract i just couldn't help myself
i know i'm a trickster this is so
mischievous
this whole asgardian theater troop thing
is one of the best jokes from thor
ragnarok
and it looks like taika ytt might be
continuing the trend but
another photo shows that he made a
little update starring someone who might
look familiar
taika uh and chris and whoever and and
the people at marvel
studios i am
i love your ice cream cakes take a good
long look everybody
you see this dreams do come true yes
melissa can be spotted sporting hela's
crown from ragnarok
alongside matt and luke onset and if you
look really closely
you can see ben in the background there
you know like behind the camera that
says
definitely his eyes the eyes don't lie
so what could this mean well the obvious
answer is that they're probably doing
another sort of
theatrical retelling this time of the
events of thor ragnarok
but i mean if it were up to me and it's
clearly not we have a version of these
guys where they actually
save the day and the whole mcu like
they're the heroes
at least give them a what if right give
the asgardian theater troupe
a what if episode whereas like what if
they stop
thanos i don't know that won't that will
never happen as always it's
just my opinion let us know what you
think is going on here in the comments
below
and should we make thor tuesdays a thing
i mean
actually thor thursdays would make more
sense thursday is literally
thor's day but you know the news can't
wait not a good week
so make sure you come on back on friday
for a full recap
of the finale of wandavision it's gonna
be a big day
see you next time